zendaya you're taller than tom and it
became this this thing and i thought
well
that much more
she's put this out there
maybe like an inch or two
it's not like people say like like how
did you guys kiss it has been so
difficult
are you wearing me no there's nothing
there i think there is something there i
think it's time that we uh secured it
[Music]
i don't know what that is do you know
what that is it's it's to make a man
taller when he's working with a giraffe
of an actress
what is this
yeah is there ever a point where you're
like i want the spider to bite mj so you
could have some superhero powers
oh no thank you i see what spider's dead
is dead
right it's dead the spider's dead what
has been your favorite quote from any
spider-man film
i'm watching porn
[Laughter]
well who's on the poster
yeah
it couldn't be cgi
it's whatever it is because it's not
it's not your upper body it's not my
upper body and i have never before in a
pose gone like that
do you remember when that when you
stupid frog thing was going on when
people talk about frogs in my mouth yeah
and you were really i got really
self-conscious about it so i now do this
all the time
just so you know yeah just so you know
there's nothing in there but also i'm
sucking the [ __ ] out of my cheeks in
there i'm going oh no
zendaya coleman and i am 25. okay tom
holland and i am 25. okay situation
familiar
uh marital situation or family situation
uh i am a son to a married couple
[Laughter]
i don't think that's what they don't
think that's what the question was but
it's funny yeah okay
do your peter parker
peter
parker
i i like american football i just will
never remember dangerous why it's called
football
because they don't use their feet i just
don't understand why it's called
football yeah it should be causally
different maybe throw ball
whatever you want to call it throw it
don't kick it
you do kick it yeah what what yeah
i was going to pretend to do something
but i didn't want the world to be like
tom holland tries to hit cinderella
[Music]
you know i like the food we got but i
don't know if anything like we do
american food what is that what is
american food though like hot dogs
i facetime i went skiing right after we
finish this movie because you know my
contract's up so finally i'm allowed to
do things that i couldn't do before like
as soon as i finished i went
snowboarding and i have an amazing photo
of me facetiming you with blood all over
my face
yeah i answered the phone you just
covered it i was like what are you doing
laughing i was like how cool is this
it's only been a few days oh man that's
very actory to do instead of the
hospital you call your girlfriend to
facetime
how much blood hey look at all this
blood on my face
everyone was like wipe it off i was like
no i look cool
[Laughter]
what's your best your best quality
that's that's hard you have so many
great qualities
yours is that you're super pretty
wow no no yours is your kindness i'd say
is your best quality you're a very kind
person i would say yours is your
selflessness you're always thinking
about others
okay okay okay
and she's pretty and you're pretty damn
where did tom holland learn acting i was
born an actor
the most is i had braces as a kid and as
a ploy to like get a discount or
something i've been in one film at the
time i did these interviews
for the orthopedics play orthopedic
orthodontist
yeah
london the best city in the world
are you know i'm actually going to go
with agree because i haven't been to all
the cities in the world and you know
lots of places have assets that london
doesn't have like you go to barcelona
you have the beach you know yeah um
and that's it so maybe it's just boston
i'm really cultured i'm like
your go-to ruining a photo face like
someone just takes my face normally just
any time my face is in it not true
my go-to face is just like
like i don't know why i just like
i'm like stuck in 2012 like
you know it's like what is that what
about playing a superhero in another
franchise
listen again
i've seen what you've had to go through
it looks awesome
how about you have you seen the growing
or change of tom
no no no okay you've grown so much
but unfortunately not in heights
we are on the same height
five foot six and a half
anyway sorry you're saying don't let
them don't let them try to take your
what would you say
um i was just gonna say that you know
you change but in all the right ways you
know you've just grown up and you've and
you've you know you have the pressure of
being spider-man in real life
um
and i think you've handled it with a lot
of grace thank you yeah spider-man's
identity
being known to the world yeah didn't see
that coming when we found out about that
we weren't happy yeah we were like
that's a big mistake you shouldn't do
that but then i think it really just
opened up
some great ideas yeah possibilities and
also we've never seen it before on the
screen you know there's no i
i haven't
well i have now
zendaya i was wondering who the best
spider-man is in your opinion tony
mcguire tom holland or andy garfield
tell me what you think
it's a very good question
i love the confidence yeah
um
listen i'm not gonna get in trouble
i'm not gonna pick a favorite but
oh
we saw from the trailer that mj and
anime is in some kind of danger so if
they both fall off from the bridge which
one would you say first
mma or mj
aunt may or mj
i i i can't answer that question yeah
sorry
is the best spiderman three i'm not
getting in trouble yeah i'm not getting
in trouble
i'm leaving it right there part of me
wanted to just flip the table then but i
was worried the legs might bang your
feet
[Music]
most likely to appear in the mcu as part
of the sinister six
venom mysterio or rhino but i like what
you did there
that was really clever you sort of
sucked us in with a really fun interview
how do you guys yeah do you guys keep
from spoiling everything how's that
how do we keep them spoiling things yeah
well we have each other
you know we check in um but you just got
to be on your toes you got to really
think about what you say before you say
it there was a question someone asked us
the other day
and uh
it was tricky yeah it was true i had to
i'd think about it for a second so i
kind of did one of these i was like
don't say it
you didn't i didn't but i didn't the
trailer came out the trailer got like
135 million views in the first hour it
was released the first hour yeah which
is like it's a good chunk of the of the
human population really watching that
trailer about half of your followers
that's pretty crazy that's crazy i
didn't know that how many views do you
think you personally were responsible
for
at least 100 million yeah right
because you've uh tweeted it or
instagramed it or did something with it
right
well it's no secret i'm not very good at
instagram is that not a secret
no oh i basically
forgot to post the trailer uh-huh i woke
up in the morning we were supposed to
approach it at 6 00 a.m yeah right and i
couldn't figure out why i was getting so
many more followers i was like this is
great how many great way to start the
day how many have you gained there's
like a couple hundred thousand oh that's
a lot yeah i was like this is amazing
and then i start scrolling and i see the
trailer and i panic and i was trying to
download the trailer from my email and i
couldn't so i had to facetime you
and she sent me a video of how to do it
so essentially i'm an old man so zendaya
you do i.t for the for the gang i'm also
that's my other job on this movie uh no
it's it's true it's really bad you think
of all people would know how to work the
web it would be spider-man we forgot you
think oh
all right what a burn thank you what a
burn thank you
jimmy
yeah yeah i know he had posted this so
remember you post a story like twice
and you're like how do i delete my story
and i had to like send you a literally i
had to screen record a video of how you
delete a story but why would it give you
the option to post it twice that's my
question
like i was like how did i do that
i don't think that's an option yeah i
think you do with them once and then
another time i don't think it's like